[Norvig] The answer is shuffle2 is still order N squared,
and you can see that because it's similar to shuffle1 in the way it goes through
and checks off the elements that are swapped.
But it is in fact correct.
It does give a balanced result that any outcome is equally likely,
and you can see that by running the shuffler test on it.
Shuffle3, on the other hand, has a nice order N runtime,
but unfortunately, it's not correct. It's biased in the results that it produces.
So in conclusion, we should stick to the original shuffle--
that is, not the teacher's function, not any attempts to fix it up,
but the one I was able to come up with in class
and the one that's in the literature of Knuth and others.